Speaker 1: We have major controversial vaccine
news from the state of California, which has
announced that California will require eligible
students in public and private schools to
be vaccinated against COVID 19.
Now the real headline should be.
California will require eligible students
in public and private schools to be vaccinated
against COVID 19.
In addition to all the other vaccines that
California students in public and private
schools already have to be vaccinated against
that because that's really what this is.
California already has a long list of requirements,
and importantly, they apply to private schools
as well.
Looking at an article from ABC7, California
will soon require all students in both public
and private schools to get the COVID vaccine
once it's authorized by the FDA for different
age groups.
Gavin Newsom announced the emergency order
Friday while visiting a middle school in San
Francisco.
The COVID vaccine will now join the list of
10 other vaccinations required for children
to attend school in the state.
The governor said the state will issue the
mandate in the next school term following
the FDA's approval.
The earliest being Jan. one 22 and the latest
being July one of 2022.
The government has fully approved the vaccine
for those 16+, but only emergency use for
12 to 15.
Once that group is fully approved, the state
will require students in seven through 12th
grades to get vaccinated.
California will require it for students in
kindergarten through sixth grade.
After that approval takes place.
At the same time, staff members at all state
schools will need to be fully vaccinated.
The state issued a mandate in August for teachers
and school staff.
Now it has eliminated the option to do regular
testing.
Instead of getting the vaccine, you just got
to get the vaccine.
Students would be granted religious and medical
exemptions, but the rules for how to split
the state would apply.
Them have not yet been written.
Any student who refuses to take the vaccine
will be forced to do independent study courses
at home.
Very important in California.
It also applies to charter schools, and it
also applies to private schools.
Charter and private schools are held to the
same standards and same curriculum requirements,
and it applies to vaccines as well.
That's not the case in all states.
That's how California is organized.
California already requires 10 vaccines to
go to school.
There are some anti-vaxxers who complain about
that, but not many.
So this is relatively uncontroversial, and
once you understand existing California law
with regard to vaccination and exemptions.
California has also really tamped down on
religious exemptions for vaccinations.
Medical is one thing, but religious they've
very much tamp down on.
You realize that there is really not much
controversy here relative to the existing
California law.
Now, if you live in a state that has completely
different laws, what's happening in California
might sound shocking.
It still shouldn't be.
It might be very much incongruous with what's
happening in your state.
But for California law, completely normal
expected, and we're going to be hearing more
about it very soon